foreign
[Music]
how big is vegar as compared to drogon
and small the two biggest dragons from
their own respective series and a dragon
from The Hobbit movies let's analyze
their sizes and get to the bottom of it
let's get to it guys
well let's start with drogon and then go
to smart and then lastly vegar and then
we will put them side by side well for
drogon we have already done a size
estimate but we will happily do it again
here for those who have not seen the
video
so here we have a scene of Jon Snow and
drogon well Jon Snow is around 5 feet 10
inches tall just a bit shy of six feet
if we put a scale that is a well a
centimeter scale but let's say that it
is in feet we can clearly see that
drogon's head is around seven feet long
and including the horns we get a total
length of around 15 feet
we can also clearly see in this other
picture his overall head length with
horns is close to 15 feet long now
taking that into account we can
juxtapose the number of heads with the
entire body and with that we get a body
length of drogon that is approximately
8.5 heads which would multiply 15 into
8.5 we will get an overall length of 127
feet we can also clearly see that in
this other pitch of drogon with the
scale adjusting to the curvature of his
body we get a length of around 130 feet
long so that's close enough
now with drogon as the base of size we
come to Vega we'll take a look at this
scene with aemon Targaryen riding her
from the episode 7 of last week the one
with him claiming the dragon and riding
her for the first time now if we bring
in drogon with Daenerys and here let's
do some bit of magic with it so we now
will be approximating the size of
Daenerys with amont Targaryen and here
we can clearly see that dragon is a
small Dragon compared to Vega we can
clearly see that drogon is just around
half the length of Vega which would make
the she Dragon an enormous Beast to
behold and it can be settled vegar at
this time is almost as big as Valerian
the black dread
now let's do the same thing with Vega
using the scale if we put in the same
scale aspect of drogon on this picture
and insert in Vega we can see that the
she dragon is around 240 feet long which
is close to our initial estimates when
we only saw the trailer scene of Vega
and also estimating the size of her
using her skull that was seen in Game of
Thrones beneath the throne room now with
that out of the way we can shift our
focus into another dragon from another
universe that is small and we will do
our own estimation of his size and
compare the end product with drogon and
Vega and settle it once and for all on
how big these three are in relation to
one another
the best approach to estimate the size
of small is to take a very cool scene
from the second Hobbit movie the one
where Thorin oakenshiel was standing
right on top of his snout we do know
that tauren was around 4 feet 10 inches
tall in the movie with some saying he's
five feet one but dwarves don't usually
go above 5 feet so as we can see using
the scale tauren at close to 5 feet is
just like a biscuit compared to small
using another image of smoke showing his
full head size the full head design we
can clearly see that the length of his
head alone would be around 20 feet but
with those small haunts they'll be
around 25 feet way more than either
dragons from Westeros in this comparison
so because Mark's Body is very
Serpentine it is quite difficult to
estimate his total body length but let's
just have a go at it nonetheless here we
have a total of 16 smart heads totaling
his overall body length using the same
Technique we did earlier with each head
measuring 25 feet including small horns
we get a total length of 400 feet and
that puts Mouse length as much as
Godzilla's height
so he can be termed as a small Kaiju
bees okay so here is the comparison
drogon is 120 to 130 feet long next is
the enormous vegar at around 240 feet
and lastly the great fire Drake smiled
at 400 feet
so that's it I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit the like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash that Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel
till the next one take care fam
[Music]